abenteuer alpen wird ihnen präsentiert
von leo p der geschmack der schweiz seit
11 115
[Musik]
sagen
märz
[Musik]
frankreich morlock sieben menschen sind
aufgebrochen und sich einen traum zu
erfüllen
es ist ihr erster tag auf der berühmten
roten und einer skitour quer durch die
alpen von chamonix nach zermatt
80 kilometer 7000 höhenmeter in sechs
tagen von hütte zu hütte
die gruppe hat sich heute zum ersten mal
gesehen
mit dabei die olympiasiegerin und
ehemalige weltcup fahrerin dominique
gisin sowie ihre frühere skirennfahrer
kollegin fränzi aufdenblatten david
fasel ist ihr bergführer zusammen mit
projekt im ehemaligen rettungschef von
zermatt auch dabei der ceo der allianz
gruppe schweiz ein heilpädagoge eine
tochter mit ihrem vater und eine junge
frau die in gedenken an ihre verstorbene
mutter auf der tour dabei ist
die ortrud durch die höchsten berge der
alpen ein mythos auf der ganzen welt
eine herausforderung für alle die sie
wagen vor ihnen liegen lange tage in
denen sie an ihre grenzen kommen werden
nur als team können sie die strecke
meistern
es ist ihr erster gemeinsamer abend alle
sind gespannt mit wem sie unterwegs sind
[Applaus]
und und fliegt wenn man mal im aufschlag
ich komme neues auch alice
zwischen malta sowie auf die forscher
vermutlich und ihre moment sekretärin
und wie man sport für mini plus
beratungs bildet das ist so eine
langzeitige liter schafft formiert wo
ich meine dass man sie erwartet die
schau mir das thema und für mich ist
auch immer lebensqualität setzt auf die
sechs gewinnzahlen nach 30 jahren innere
schwul der entscheid
ich finde ich höre die duftstoffe wurden
die probiere mich selbständig zu machen
und damit entscheide ich werde viel
mutiger werde ich habe mich bis jetzt
nichts was ein mutiger mensch erlebt und
jetzt ein entscheid gefällt und der
entscheidet blick auf die austria hat
mit dem arzt um ein hindernis nur
bemerkt die tägliche verfügbarkeit der
woche verabschieden entschärft
vier wochen haben wir einfach sobald ich
zusätzlich vor der affäre
geschäftsleitung und so weiter und ich
haben jetzt nämlich organisieren dass
ich stets überbrückt und das ist ein
kluger und dann habe ich dann definitiv
zurück alleinerziehende mutter
verzweifelt niveau aber gehalten und
schaffe zu 60 prozent aus oberstufe mini
fried beschreibt sich auf sehr wenig dem
moment wo die wirklich neu bis kann
mache ich bin schon öfter euro trug sie
vor 50 jahren
und das hat mich schon immer
interessiert weg sieht das hübsch ist
die ganze umgebung für wichtig dass dort
die letzte wahrheit noch auf die sie
durch ihre mutter quasi geld und sie
sind da wenn man die taxi und löst ja
wahrheit denn sie verbrachten oder wieso
ist sie so gern der ak und so zum screen
aus china verwiesen darauf dass ich noch
spezielle
auf der uhr tritt wollen alle eine
auszeit von ihrem alltag nehmen
bergführer david fasel aus verviers
führt seit jahren regelmäßig gäste durch
diese route der start zur tour war heute
morgen in aschau
neben chamonix von dort ging es hoch zu
ross der hütte morgen wird die gruppe
weiter gehen zur generierung der schweiz
dann über werke hoch zur berufung von
dort in die kaverne dies ins biwak
dokter die ankunft ist am sechsten tag
in zermatt 7000 höhenmeter 80 km
meistens auf 3000 metern höhe inmitten
der viertausender warten auf das team
14 uhr am sitz der wieder anschauen ist
auch nicht boxer kanada sondern damit
1000 euro am morgen hektisch die presse
gewandt
[Musik]
der nächste morgen beginnt mit einer
unangenehmen überraschung
langsam david phasen wird heute mehr
verantwortung übernehmen müssen
[Applaus]
nach karl langsam baut die sache mit dem
stand zwar zwischen zwischen ahnt nicht
mehr doch bis die sonderfälle dezember
barroso verhindern und das schnittgut
wechsel des superstars nach einer
eiskalten nacht ist der schnee petit hat
und die erste abfahrt führt durch
steiles gelände vor solchen passagen
hatte der 72 jährige paul zeller bereits
im vorfeld respekt
[Musik]
ceo severin moser muss eingreifen
er hilft dass paul nicht in die steilen
felsen abrutscht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sony corp
[Musik]
die nächste schwierigkeit wartet bereits
der aufstieg zum col de romme planen wie
diesen anleger die auf europas bühne
die wenigsten haben bisher viel
erfahrung mit dem gehen auf steigeisen
muss ich dass es so
ich meine die stetige und schufen rücken
aufgebrochen ist die gruppe heute in der
schau die hütte jetzt sind sie im ersten
aufstieg auf den golden chardonnay
weiter geht's über das für das allein
zur besteigung derek wie du tun
ziel ist die kabarett trio auf 3.170
meter über 10 km und 1040 höhenmeter
beinhaltet dieser tag dafür sind fünf
bis sieben stunden reine laufzeit
geplant
[Musik]
es ist gut dass sie etwas abgewinnen
es ist der erste test bergführer david
muss herausfinden wie sicher die gruppe
unterwegs ist aber der erste ist braucht
er geht ganz gut ich habe doch stutzig
[Applaus]
direkt hinter dem 72 jährigen paul seine
tochter yolanda
jeder sucht seinen eigenen rhythmus in
knapp 3000 metern höhe nicht nur carmen
und peter auch die ehemalige
spitzensportlerin dominik risi
bruno jelk folgt geschwächt von seiner
magenverstimmung
sogar bis trento seine brüder finde ich
nicht nichts wie truck tour gebrauch zu
machen wir jetzt mal langsam
brings nötig damit sich die diesel auf
vertragsmonat ist oder aus dem ausland
die quelle aber es gibt einfach ein
andere sicherheiten diesem frühen morgen
früher und mit speziellen dennoch ist
einfach da so viel sicherer und ist
achter zu laufen ja viele aufziehen und
reisen und tiere
dominik referenzen unter die arme jetzt
sieht er noch nase zuerst
700 meter auf stehen auch die ehemaligen
weltcup fahrerinnen sind technisch
gefordert da der stille
ausgerechnet er leidet heute am meisten
rojek der er sich gewohnt ist als
bergführer voraus zu gehen und die
ortrud bestens kennt
das letzte chance um chance aber oder
nehmen wir aber der flosse aber wie geht
es ja doch wie geht es mit bruno weiter
die grippe ist groß es braucht zwei
bergführer um sicher durch die woche zu
kommen
nach drei stunden ist der goldi
chardonnay in griffnähe
das tor zu den walliser alpen
[Musik]
3323 meter sind erreicht
die grenze zwischen frankreich und der
schweiz
dahinter ein steiles kuba der karabiner
löse die zweiteilige nicht verstellt xl
habe für den handel aber laufen
aber hier wurde eine neue seele und so
sieht der entwurf aber mit bei der grat
zusammen mit david sicher die passage
mit einem seil muss einfach nicht
klappen
jolanda macht den anfang aber ich kann
auch nicht dort stehen auch weil sie der
präsident dann pixel nadal hat jetzt
gemütlich haben opfer her ist gut für
yolanda ist der abstieg kein problem
denn sie ist es weiterhin als nächstes
ist die vater paul so dass ich für ihn
ist das bitter
raul hat ein cluster und aber laufen
wirklich
oben wartet peter nervös ob es
zuversichtlich
gut dass sie nein das ist nicht nur eine
visitenkarte für mich sondern auch eine
figur
das startgewicht straflos und drogbas
ganz am anfang so langsam gehen die man
ihm und richtig klar stadtgrün seiner so
am fix hannover lagen sagen
ein weiterer schritt mutig zu sein
auch frenzel macht sich bereits da sind
für den witzen töpfl ich schieße man es
braucht
ich war schon ganz verschieden aber es
wäre jetzt sicherlich auch dadurch aber
für das sie wieder die olympiasiegerin
bringt sich in position als einzige war
dominique gisin die abfahrt im engen und
steilen kurve
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deutlich steigern
ein sturz am anfang der tour möchte sich
dominique nicht leisten sie die oft in
ihrer heimat engelberg am freeriden ist
jolanda nutzt die pause für eine sms
denn er war schon als christliche bild
lichtfuß einem indischen zum beispiel
als christlicher familien
jetzt kann das ist gut und da hat sich
[Musik]
die gruppe ist jetzt seit fünf stunden
unterwegs
die sonne brennt auf den gletschern es
geht hinauf zum nächsten feld übergangen
zum finale das allein vorbei an offenen
gletscherspalten ein fehltritt kann
fatale folgen haben
[Musik]
jolanda hilft ihrem vater zur sicherheit
zieht die gruppe die steigeisen an sich
aber nicht ändern
oktober machen länger nach fonds liegt
ein peters dieser richtige aktie
damit nimmt die skis von paul yolanda
geht auch ohne steigeisen
es folgen weitere 100 meter steile
aufstiege bis zum vertreters allein mit
ski und gepäck auf dem buckel der schnee
wird durch die hitze immer weicher
die gruppe hat bereits einige höhenmeter
in den beinen
und es ist erst der zweite tag der tour
[Musik]
vater und tochter sind die ersten
aber es hat auch etwas was ich sehr
streng
das wirkliche problem projekt der mann
der sein leben lang gewohnt war auf der
ganzen welt leben zu retten musste im
aufstieg sein gepäck abgeben müssen
also probierte der wechsel mit dem spiel
das bringt nämlich das spitzdach david
plante er weil eine zusätzliche
klettertour der ball oder beete mit dem
bruno zur wehr noch kraft und energie
hat will sich den zusätzlichen gipfel
nicht entgehen lassen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der gipfel zu verlocken der aussieht ist
nicht für alle realistisch bruno fährt
mit paul und peter über den gletscher
direkt zur bahn
während die anderen wieder aufsteigen zu
reggae die 2
[Musik]
es ist unterdessen mittag die sonne
brennt vom himmel
nach dem eiskalten morgen jetzt
sommertemperaturen auf 3000 metern höhe
die trinkflaschen sind fast leer
der proviant gegessen die hitze setzt
allen zu
auch olympiasiegerin dominique gisin
kämpft
und die kletterpartie steht noch bevor
heute reden wir schließlich nicht
[Musik]
oder halt einfach ich glaub mir so
richtig
die nächsten jahre peter bruno und paul
sind fast schon am ziel
die kabarett trio ist ein alter steinbau
die erste hütte auf schweizer boden
übernachtet wird auf 3.170 metern
bruno nicht wiederhole
[Applaus]
als erfahrener bergführer kennt bruno
die strapazen der note gut und weiß wer
nicht hundertprozentig fit ist kann die
tour nicht durchstehen
danke
die hochrechnung zum hit und der dieb
von der mosel rätsel unbedingt will
ich muss mich nicht dafür belohnen die
zweite republik die hüft operationen
kommt und das ist eine detaillierte
rückschlag über und natürlich mit bus
report und das dass das match und also
er rief die teile das merkt oh das ist
eine 650 nehmen service mag sie es kommt
klar
inzwischen ist david mit seiner gruppe
kurz vor dem gipfel
schon
alle sind mitgekommen auch carmen
[Musik]
nach über sieben stunden ist der erste
gipfel der tour erreicht
[Musik]
und du du vielleicht morgen wenn die
blutserum in afrika
so verstehe ich jetzt des schnittes
links fuhr der frachter
[Applaus]
schweren herzens hat bruno entschieden
mit dem heli der für kamerateams und
transport zuständig ist ins tal zu
fliegen
bruno fühlt sich nicht mehr in der lage
weiter zu machen und hofft dass er sich
in zermatt erholen kann und vielleicht
später noch einmal zurückzukommen
[Musik]
währenddessen freut sich davids gruppe
auf eine lange abfahrt
ich habe noch die funktion drehen
rechten fleck
[Musik]
eine entschädigung für all die strapazen
nach über acht stunden werden die gipfel
stürme in der kabarett trio erwartet
abziehen wäre das haben morgens wenn ich
trinke er was zu wahren wurde das
hintere glied und ich kaufen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der papa 30 interessierte wieder bis zum
ralf weber der bergführer das filmteam
zuständig ist hat sich carmen angenommen
herrschaft motto ich habe zweimal
vorher wäre super laufen die
wirklichkeit und machte aus ihr mir die
axalp bioanalytik platzangst sich nur
keine weg um den ist es wirklich
rechtsstaat oder abgang und höre ist
jetzt ein minister wie flügel das super
gefunden
ceo severin moser genießt die pause
na ja auch noch nicht schmeckt und was
man auch stets mit severin moser ist
ehemaliger zehnkämpfer und trainiert
noch heute täglich als ceo bei der
allianz schweiz führt der 3500
mitarbeiter und hat sich vorgenommen in
dieser woche keine mails zu beantworten
ach der ist meldet in ihnen leben
eigentlich eine falsche geschlecht
gewisse ein helfer sprechen hören dank
der andere den gegen die witzigsten und
und mache der bitte sich irgendwo da
oben und startete sagen wir haben
darüber sollen es tolles panorama mit
herzlichkeit rein es wichtig mehr im
ganzen friedlich in einem ganz erreicht
und natürlich hat man in exponierter
funktionen und wahrscheinlich eine
wichtige funktion
aber man ist auch jeder ersetzbar und
haben sich nicht allzu wichtig nimmt
danach eine den kommenden wochen
bestellt
zu ersetzen ist nun blue new york mit
seinem abgang hat das team den zweiten
bergführer verloren
ich selber woche ist problem morgen und
aber so aber wird dieses thema
gesprochen wir da noch erfahrene partner
t wenn man diese weise schafft der mache
ist einfach sehr sein führen patient
diese chance ist das cockpit
[Gelächter]
david will mit saz tourenleiter yolanda
vorerst alleine weitermachen und hofft
dass bruno wieder fit wird
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen ist um 34 tag war
jeden tag über nacht die gruppe
gemeinsam in einer anderen hütte
der ablauf des nordens folgt an dem
ritual zuerst den rucksack packen das
gepäck für eine woche tragen alle selber
bist du zehn kilo inklusive steigeisen
und pickel wiegt ein rucksack bevor es
losgeht findet die kontrolle der
lawinensuchgeräte statt
[Applaus]
der bauhof und enden irgendwann der
dauernd auf der fläche geworden
jeder muss bei yolanda vorbeifahren ein
piepsen zeigt an dass die
lawinensuchgeräte eingeschaltet sind
das wetter ist bisher stabil und auch
die prognosen sehen gut aus
[Applaus]
wieder stehen rund sechs stunden
aufstieg traversen und abfahrten über
3000 meter höhe bevor die kalten
morgenstunden sind wichtig und geben
sicherheit
die gruppe muss gegen 14 uhr in der
nächsten heute sein da es am nachmittag
wieder heiß werden soll und damit die
gefahr von nassschneelawinen steigt
[Musik]
dann ein abfallendes steilstücken mit
einer schneeverwehung einer wechte dass
der zaun vor der show war dabei aktuell
erreichte sie beständig einfach immer
wieder glauben dann nach hamburg gemacht
und bewusst
und jetzt weiß sie sich bewusst dass man
die andere problem sei nicht dass gut
und das sehen sie in der nächsten folge
ein vereister steilhang fordert die
gruppe am frühen morgen zu
bewährungsprobe für yolanda als
tourenleiter
freud durchaus groß
endlich 2000 meter abfahrt für die
beiden weltcup fahrerin dominique gisin
und fränzi aufdenblatten sowie ein
bekenntnis jetzt wirklich eine
freundschaft und die andere die sich
halt nicht grad so dass wir entweder und
peter kommt ins grübeln dann fang zu
drehen wer wen ich etwas mache ich da
überhaupt und kirche die gruppe der
könig nötige gruppen und wie so hoch lag
ich mit schwarzem
[Musik]
dies und mehr gleichen zweiten teil in
abenteuer alten die spur des lebens
[Musik]
abenteuer alben wurde ihnen präsentiert
von locri er hob i der geschmack der
schweiz seit 11 115
[Musik]